so get this two years ago Harvard
scholars discovered a copy of the
Declaration of Independence in a most
unlikely place a public records office
over in England the document was then
sent to the British Library for further
tests and now science is able to tell a
bit more of the story Elizabeth Palmer
reports this is what's now known as the
Sussex Declaration after the English
county where Harvard researchers
discovered it handwritten on parchment
it's a word-for-word copy of the
document written by the founding fathers
right down to the signatories carefully
copied out by a long-dead clerk dr.
Cristina Duffy is an imaging scientists
at the British Library it's real it's
definitely real period piece from
shortly after the Declaration of
Independence itself absolutely but why
was it made and when here's a clue in
one corner somebody's tried to erase the
date but with UV light Duffy was able to
bring the numbers back at least partly
our theory is its fourth of July 17 80s
or 1790s so that means a decade or two
after the u.s. declared independence
from Britain scholars think it was
commissioned by James Wilson a patriot
and a judge who may have wanted his very
own copy to put on show we also found
some traces of iron around the corners
of the document around some tears which
suggests that it might have been pinned
up with nails at some point as a
ceremonial piece of parchment there is
one other ceremonial copy it's kept at
the National Archives in Washington it
was Harvard researchers professor
Danielle Allen and Emily Smith who went
on a hunt to find every copy of the
Declaration that survived every copy of
the Declaration of Independence has a
different story it has a different
method of production a different
audience and a different you know piece
in the history of this important
document and the words of it that
continue to inspire us this precious
version arrived at the West Sussex
archive unremarked in the 1950s in a
batch of legal doc
at last rediscover and says archivist
Wendy Walker it's giving up at least
some of its secrets it was written in
the States either probably in
Philadelphia or New York we know where
it ended up in 1956 what we need to find
out is what happened in between and
that's the the research that's still
still ongoing and while it does the
Sussex declaration will be refiled
carefully back on the shelves where it's
at unnoticed for so long for CBS this
morning Saturday
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in London very
story by Liz there i wouldn't know who
put the copy away lost this thing i love
how that each one of these copies has a
story of its own it's yes it's and there
are so few out there it's so exciting
right I found it and how bizarre that
the date had been arranged yes what was
that about yeah there's a story there
too won't to be told